では礼拝、三帰依、五戒文から始まります
（司会）合掌してください
（三帰依）Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sammā Sambuddhassa.
阿羅漢であり、正自覚者であり、福運に満ちた世尊に、私は敬礼したてまつる。
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sammā Sambuddhassa.
Buddhaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
私は仏陀に帰依いたします。
Dhammaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
私は法（真理）に帰依いたします。
Sanghaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
私は僧（聖者の僧団）に帰依いたします。
Dutiyam pi Buddhaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
再び私は仏陀に帰依いたします。
Dutiyam pi Dhammaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
再び私は法（真理）に帰依いたします。
Dutiyam pi Sanghaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
再び私は僧（聖者の僧団）に帰依いたします。
Tatiyam pi Buddhaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
三たび私は仏陀に帰依いたします。
Tatiyam pi Dhammaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
三たび私は法（真理）に帰依いたします。
Tatiyam pi Sanghaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi.
三たび私は僧（聖者の僧団）に帰依いたします。
（五戒）Pāṇātipātā veramaṇī sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
私は「生き物を殺さない」という戒めを受けて守ります。
Pāṇātipātā veramaṇī sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
Adinnādānā veramaṇī sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
私は「与えられていないものを取らない」という戒めを受けて守ります。
Kāmesu micchācārā veramaṇī sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
私は「淫らな行為をしない」という戒めを受けて守ります。
Musāvādā veramaṇī sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
私は「いつわりをかたらない」という戒めを受けて守ります。
Surāmeraya Majjapamādaṭṭhānā veramaṇī sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
私は「放逸の原因となり、（人を）酔わせる酒類、麻薬などを使用しない」という戒めを受けて守ります。
では、慈悲の瞑想をいたします
私は幸せでありますように
私の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私の願いごとが叶えられますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
私は幸せでありますように
私は幸せでありますようにと
念じます
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように
私の親しい生命の悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
私の親しい生命の願いごとが
叶えられますように
私の親しい生命に悟りの光が現れますように
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように
親しい生命が幸せでありますようにと
繰り返し念じます
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
生きとし生けるものの願いごとが
叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものに悟りの光が
現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと繰り返し念じます
私の嫌いな生命が幸せでありますように
私の嫌いな生命の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私の嫌いな生命の願いごとが叶えられますように
私の嫌いな生命に悟りの光が現れますように
私を嫌っている生命が幸せでありますように
私を嫌っている生命の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私を嫌っている生命の願いごとが叶えられますように
私を嫌っている生命に悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
はい。ありがとうございます
では、今年ぐらいでもよいお年で
ありますようにと誓願いたします
自分の国では、最近の…
なんと言いますかユーモアの
言葉がありましてね
面白かったんです
で、ラジオ番組で聴いたんですけどね
アナウンサー二人が
先に相手に言う
しゃべろうと思ったら…
「今年…」と言ったとたん「やめてください」と
「あなた『今年も幸福に満たされた年
でありますように』と祝福したいと
思っているでしょう」と
「やめてください」と
「だって去年も同じことをやったでしょうに
…なってないでしょう」と
「ずーっとそうやって
新年の挨拶をしてるんだけど
全然、したからと言って
幸せになってないんだ」と
そこで「私もあなたに去年祝福したでしょう？
幸福になった？」相手も「なってない」と
「でしょう？だからやめてください」と（笑）
よけいなことで（笑）
という冗談で終わったんですけどね
まあ、経験を考えてみれば
そんなのはしきたりで
言うだけで誰も真面目に心から
祝福するということはしないみたいですね
言わなかったらマズイと（笑）
そんな感じになってるんです
そういう祝福はあんまり
効き目がないんですね
できれば…我々がお互いに
祝福するのはすごくいい習慣ですけど
それはちょっと心を込めて
本気で祝福するならば
お互いに何となく気分が良くなって
よい状態に
なる可能性はありますよ
心はみんなつながっているし
心の力で生きているんだからね
その心をよい心に入れ替えれば
いい事になるのは
当然当たり前だと思います
とにかく皆さまに大変よい
無事な
いろんな苦しみを乗り越えられる
力が備わった
よい年でありますように、ということで
新年の挨拶といたします
すごく長い…
なんていいますか…
Longtime banですね
すごく長い時間
皆さまに会わなかったんですから
私は日本語を忘れてしまって（笑）
で、今日、やっと
一般公開の講演…
できたようなんですけど
なんか日にちが近づいてくると
もう一度…
コロナ様が
がんばり始めたんですからね
まあ、今回はそれほど
重症になって
死に至るところまではないので
まあ、ほとんど感染した方々は
自分の家にいるだけで十分ということに
なってはいるんですね
まあ、英語でもいろんな
新しい単語ができているんですね
はい
今日のテーマに入りましょうね
早く終わった方がいいと思いますね（笑）
ずーっと仲良く一緒にいたら
どうか分からないですけどね
とにかく一緒になったんだから、感染するなら
とっくに感染してると思いますけどね（笑）
どうしたって意味がないんです（笑）
今日は、すごく苦労しました
今日のタイトルを作るために
日本語は出てこないんですね
今日のタイトルは
”What is righteousness?" なんですね
righteousness っていう英語の単語は
日本語で言えば「正義」っていうことなんですね
正義とはなにか？と
英語で文章を読む方々にとっては
"What is sin?" 悪はなんですか
というテーマで
色んなものが書かれてはいるんですね
誰も"What is right?"
"What is righteousness?" という
疑問は作ってないんですね
「正義」って何なのか？と
英語で righteousness っていうのは
まあ、正義でしょうね
正しい生き方、道徳的な生き方
モラルをちゃんと守って
しっかり、正しく生きるという
意味なんですね
でもそれが何なのか、と
はい、進めます
ふだん私はいろんな
家の中のくだらん…
まあ、一回りしてね
さまよって、やっとテーマに戻るという…
ことをやっていたんですが、いきなり
ブッダの世界からスタートします
お釈迦様の教えを皆さま、暗記してますね
これだと
Sabba pāpassa akaraṇaṃ kusalassa upasampadā,
これはすべてのブッダたちの
正等覚者たちの指導ですね
まだ、たくさんありますけど
同じ偈の中でね
まあ一行と二行だけ
今日は取り上げました
Sabba pāpassa akaraṇaṃ というのは
一切の悪を犯さないこと
kusalassa upasampadā,
善に達すること
あるいは善になること
これは、私はすごく
威張ってこういう訳にしているんです
なぜならば、みんななんとなく
固定概念で
悪を犯さないこと
善を行うことだと訳すんですね
これって頭が悪いんです
ブッダの教えじゃないんです
誰だって言えることでしょうに
ブッダの「悪を犯さないこと」それは
Do not do なんですね
Do not commit evel.
絶対やるなよ、と
kusalassa upasampadā
っていうのは
善に「なりなさい」なんです
「やりなさい」ではないんです
自分自身が善に
なってしまうんですね
英語のフレーズはあります
Be good.
Do good ではなくてね
Be good と言ったら、英語のフレーズだったら
目指すところは、「いいな」と思う
簡単なことだと思うんです
昔、シンガポールなんか行ったら
シンガポールの人々の車とかね
タクシーにもあるんだけど
まあ、ほとんど仏教の方々だからね
ステッカーを貼っていたんですね
そのステッカーにあったのは
Everybody can go to heaven.
Just be good.
それのステッカーなんですね
誰でも、誰でも天界に行けますよ、と
ただ Be good.
よい人間になれ、と
Do good と言ったとたん、
なんかすごーく負担がかかります
「ああ、そうですか
やらなきゃならないですかねー」とかね
「ああ、大変だ」とかね（笑）
「仕事が忙しくて…どうすれば…」
という、色んな精神的なストレスが
妄想が割り込んでくるんです
Be good と言ったら
そこはあまりないんですね
完全たる善人になれるようにと
説かれると、
我々は基本的に汚れている
悪人ではないかと思われるんですね
それから私の観察ですけど
もしお釈迦様が
「善になりなさい」と言ったら
「え？我々は悪人でしょうかねぇ」
…ということはなんとなく裏にあるんですね
もともと悪人でなければ
別にお節介を言わなくていいでしょうに
しかしお釈迦様が他宗教のように
「汝らは生まれつき罪人だ」という
「原罪」というね
Born Evil という言葉は使ってないんです
Human-beings are born evil
という言葉は、キリスト教文化で
よく使う言葉なんですね
ここで、善とはなに？悪とはなに？
という定義が必要です
そこで、なにが善、なにが悪という
定義が必要になります
はい、次に進みます
そこで、行為の判断基準
結果が良いか悪いかということで
行為は善か悪かと判断できます
だいたい仏教的な考えですね
結果が悪いんだったら行為が悪かったね
よい結果になったら
ああ、行為はよい行為であったと
だから善行為悪行為っていうのは
結果で判断できる
しかし結果は既に起きているので、
直すことが出来ませんね
これまずいですね
人を刺してみたら人が死んじゃったんですね
それで結果が悪いね
あんた、どうする？それからは
直すことはできないねぇ
だから結果で善悪を判断する場合は
そういう弱点があるんです
やってから結果が出るんだからね
もう結果が出たら後戻りも
何もできませんね
人が火遊びをして家が火事になった、と
火事になったことが悪い結果ですね
火遊びは楽しいんですね
楽しい行為をしたら
結果が悪かったんだから
あの楽しい行為も悪行為になるんだけど
家が火事になってからは
後の祭りで、もうどうにもならないですね
しかしまあ「これから気をつけなさい」
とは言えますけどね
やはり再び、二度と、同じ
過ちを犯さないという
そういう風に自己管理できますね
こういうことをやって悪い結果になった
じゃあ二度とやりません、と
なんかカッコよさそうに見えますね
そう言うと
でもそちらにも問題があるんでしょうに
しかし、ある時点で悪い結果を出した行為が、
別な時空関係で良い結果を出す可能性もありますね
だから、二度とやらんと決めてもねぇ
例えば 子供を叱ってはならないですね
子供を怒鳴ったり、怒ってはいけませんよ？
「じゃあやらない」と決めても
時々…出ますね。子供を…やっぱり
いきなり怒鳴ってあげないと
危険なことをやってしまうっていう
場面もありますね
はい、そういう風に
道徳世界に入って来ると、なんか…
どうも…うまく…
うまく行かないとか、はっきり
決定できないところがある
ということは理解してください
それは仏教だけは解決してあげますよ？
今日は他宗教やら哲学を
参考にしてないのは
まあ、怠けたことは
確かなんですけど（笑）
それほど、世間では道徳を
くっきりとさせてないんです
いつでも曖昧中途半端にしてるんです
それで仏教の結論は
こころ、意欲、意思、要求などの
心所が
行為を引き起こすんですからね
我々には心があるんですね
生命にもありますよ
その心が「こうやりなさい」と
指令するんですね
例えば
まあ
Leopard（ヒョウ）がサバンナにいる
あるいはライオンでもいいんだけど
お腹が空いてるんですね
そこで心が「食いなさい」という
指令を出すんです
あるいは言葉では出てきません
気持ちで
「なにか食いたい」という
気持ちが生まれるんです
人間は言葉にするんだけど
他の生命は言葉にはしない
フィーリングだけでストップするんです
それから、この Leopard が
獲物を追っかけて
鹿を追っかけていかなくちゃいけないですね
気持ちもなく
こういうことをしません
例えばライオンがお腹いっぱいだったら
自分の前で鹿が歩いたからといって
気にもしない
まあ吠えてあげるくらい…？
…ない
寝る
だからここは
意欲を作らないんですね
「これは食べ物だ、食べなさい」と
そういうことで、我々人間の場合は…
我々にとっては
心の気持ちをチェックすると
行為をやるかやらないか
次に判断することができます
それで、無事道徳を守って
生きられることができます
それは詳しく皆さん
ご存知だと思いますけど、例えば
怒りがこみ上げてくる
自分が怒ったのは前にいる人の
存在だと判断する
まあそれは間違ってる判断ですけど
仕方がないんですね
この人の生き方、しゃべり方、生活習慣が
変だからということで自分が怒ってるんですね
それで怒りの感情があるんですね
そうすると何かやりたくて
エネルギーが溜まるんですね
でも行為の意味を持つのは
怒りの感情なんですね
だから怒りの感情は悪いと
判断するならば
行為をストップした方がいいんですね
怒鳴りたくなっていたならば
怒鳴らないことにする
不機嫌な顔を見せようと
思っていたならば
あるいは威嚇の顔を見せようと
していたならば
それはやめて、居る
そうすると悪いことをしないで
すみます
はい、次に行きます
そこでよく見えることは、これは
個人が判断しなくてはいけないですね
だって心は個人のものだからね
どうにもならん
個人のものなんです
行為は個が行うもので
個が判断するんですね
個人に善悪判断能力が必要です
これで問題が起こるんです
一人ひとりの人に、善と悪を
区別する能力が必要なんです
やれやれ…と
こんな能力を持って生まれる訳じゃないね
何が良いか、何が悪いか
知って生まれる訳じゃないんです
そこで
人は他人から学ぶ生命体ですから
皆、他人が決めた基準に従って
行動するんです
それでいいかどうかは
分からないね
我々がどんな人間かということは
他人が決めたんですね
まあ、誰でも親と
おじいさんおばあさんなどが
色々な物を教えるんですね
「これは悪い、これはいい」とかね
孫を作ってたくさん言葉を
教えるんですよ
ご飯を食べるときの座り方も
教えてくれるわ
ご飯を食べるときはふざけるなよ
とか教えてくれるわ
食べるものをこぼすなよと
教えるわ、ね
いろんなことで、たくさん
善悪を教えてるんですね
靴を脱いだら揃えておきなさいと
教えるわ
それで、まあ大人になっていく過程で
親だけではなくて
色んな人々から色んなことを
教えてもらうんですね
そこでトラブルがあるんですよ
教える人の能力
例えば若者が反政府グループに
入ったとしましょう
ヤクザグループに入ったとしましょう
「ヤクザがいい」ということでね
カッコいいと
入ったら、そちらでやるべきこと
やってはいけないことを教えるでしょうに
犯罪グループだから
「犯罪はやるべきこと」
…だと教えるんですね
それで入った若者がじわじわと
悪行為することを訓練して
慣れていくんですね
だから問題が起きますよ？
「誰から道徳を学ぶべきですか」と
道徳世界はどこでも
トラブル、トラブルですね
「じゃあ親から学びましょう」
と言っても
親は何でも知ってる
訳じゃないんですね
大人になったら
親の責任が終わっちゃうんですね
親にとっては、小ちゃいときから
赤ちゃんのときから育てたんだから
そのイメージが消えませんね
だからしっかりした大人になってからは
ちょっと教えることはできなくなりますね
例えば日本の国で総理大臣という人が
いるとしましょう
その人にも親がいるんだからね
だから、総理大臣として
立派な人間として
どう善悪判断して
生きるのかということは
母親には教えられないんです
母親にとっては「自分の息子」
それで終わり
家の中でだらしないことをやったら
怒ることはできますけどね
社会で国会でやってることについては
何にもアドバイスできないんですね
だから「親の躾で生活しましょう
死ぬまで」と言っても
これも足りないし
他の人からも教えてもらわなくちゃいけないし
それって、本当に相手には
ならないんですよ？
だからとにかく自分で
判断する能力があれば
何とかなりますけどね
はい
次に行きます
それでこの道徳っていうものは
けっこう変化するんですね
止まってないんです
だから、これがいい生き方だと
自分たちが思っているものが
ちょっと変わってしまう
そうすると…
社会は笑っちゃう
「あんた、なんでこんなことをやるの？」と
あまりいい例は思い出せませんけど
例えば日本では、ご飯を食べる前に
本当のところは手を合わせて
手を合わせて「いただきます」
と言わなくちゃいけないんですね
みんなやってないでしょう、
そういう風に
ちょっと変わってるんですね
ちゃんと丁寧に手を合わせて
いただきます、と言った方がいいんです
それがしっかりした習慣ですね
では、世界中どこへ行っても
自分がそういうことをやると
ちょっとなんか…
変に思われることもあり得る
あるいはまあ無視するということもね
「そんな決まりはどうでもいいや」という風にね
あるんだから
我々はどこまで真剣に道徳を
守るべきかっていうことで
困るんですね
そこで、宗教…
それから社会
それから時代
そういう組織が
善悪を決めるんですね
宗教が善悪を決めるのは
宗教は自分の仕事だと思ってますけど
その宗教を信仰していないならば
どうしますかね？
だから宗教が三つくらいあって
それぞれの道徳セットが違いますからね
豚肉を食べていいか悪いか
肉を食べていいか悪いかとかね（笑）
それぞれの宗教によって
違う…
…ことにもなりますね
ユダヤ人の人と友達になったら
ご飯を食べるときは大変困ると思いますよ
いろんな…食べることに…
色々…
規則があるんだからね
そういうことで、国によって、地方によって
信仰によって、社会によって
道徳は変わるんです
結果どうなってますか、と
地球に一貫した善悪基準がないんですね
だからどうすればいいんですかね
どうやって良い人間になれますかねぇ
そこで、こう決めたら？
自分好みの、自分が気に入った
道徳リスト、道徳セットがあって
それに従順で、真面目に道徳的に生きる、と
それが正しい、と
それだったら、すべての人類が個人だから
個人個人が自分の道徳を持ってるんですからね
そうするとけっきょくは
何も批判できなくなりますね
「あんたの生き方はちょっとおかしい」とかね
ということは世界にあるどんな生き方も
オーケーということにしなくてはいけない
これも問題なんですね
だって世界で殺人者もいるんだからね
人を犯す人もいるんだからね
強盗をやる人もいるんだから
自爆テロをやっている人もいるんだからね
みんな自分に適した道徳システムを
信仰しています
だからテロリストに話を聞くと
「そこは善行為だ」と、テロ行為は
…言うでしょう
「じゃあ、どうぞ」と言える？
どうぞ爆弾を仕掛けてください、と
あんたは自由です、と
難しいね
だからそれに答えに出てくるのではなくて
社会が全体的に道徳を…
「こう生きなさい」と
例えば法律
あれ、すごく強引ですね
法律みたいに道徳をしっかり決めておく、と
そうするとみんな一貫して同じ
道徳を守ることはできますけど
しかし人が自分で判断するものだからね
道徳はね
やるか、やらないか、とか
そちらで人の自由がなくなって
しまうんです
みんな、なんかロボットに
なってしまうんです
ロボットになって生きていても…
これって道徳でしょうかねぇ？
はい次に行きます
けっこう疲れました
仏教は、個人が判断するべき
個人が判断して生きているっていう
ことにしているんですね
そうなってくると
生きることが道徳なんです
生きることは個人の仕事なんです
他人にどうすることもできないんです
病院なんかに行ったらよく分かるでしょうに
病気を治すか、治らないか
そのまま死ぬかっていう
これ個人の力なんですね
誰にもどうすることもできませんね
医学システムがあるからと言って
治すことはできないんです
施しはするんだけど
身体が自分で治さなくてはいけません
生きることは自分の行為ですね
そこで人間にありますね
「生き続けたい」
死にたくないという衝動がありますね
この「死にたくない」「生きていきたい」
という衝動、エネルギーで
我々は、行動を起こしたり
しゃべったり、考えたり
いろんなことをやったりしますね
すべて生き続けるためにやってるんです
それに気づいたらどうですか、と
そこで、また問題が起こります
私は生きていきたい
死にたくないんだから
生き続けるために必要な判断をしながら
行為をしています
まあ生きられるならば善行為で
私がやったことで死んじゃったならば
悪行為になる
例えば
生き続けたいんだから、なにか食べる
生き続けたいんだから食べると言って
何か食べたところで
食べたものが体に当たって病気になったら
自分が悪行為をやったことになるんですね
そこで判断しなくてはいけませんね
これは食べて、これは食べない、とかね
なぜならば生きていきたいんですね
自分も体に良いものを選んで食べたならば
その人は健康で生きられます
はい、それでうまく行くかというと
うまく行かないんですね
なぜならば
すべての生命も同じ衝動で生きてるんです
それで、行為の間で
ぶつかり合いが起こるんです
私が「生き続けたい」とやってることは
他の生命にとってはすごく迷惑になったりする
そうするとその生命は生きていきたいんだから
私の行為をやらせない
邪魔をする
私に攻撃する
これはずーっとあることですよ？
会社で仕事をするときでも
このトーナメントが起こるんです
同じ会社の仲間だからみんな仲良く
仕事しなさいよ、と
互いに協力しあって…
…やらないよ？
できることなら誰かの
足を引っ張って
みることができれば
やっちゃいますね
相手を嫌な気分にさせたくなったら
やりますよ？
そうすると、その人は仕事を失敗して
仕事をやる気がなくなって
会社辞めてくれると自分の立場が
うまくなります
それで自分が生きられる
ライバルがいなくて
色んなところで生存の争いが
見えてくるんです
今、コロナの状況を見ていても
同じこと。生存の争いなんですね
どちらでも生き続けたいと
がんばっているんです
そういうことで、世の中で
混乱、争い、弱肉強食…
差別、搾取、管理する、管理される
などなどの問題が世の中に起きてるんです
大変なことになるんですね
すごくややこしいんですよ
この問題は
だから何が良い、何が悪いということは
生存欲で判断しなさい、と
言っても
それでもうまく行かないんですね
理由があります
生きる権利は皆に平等にあるが
生かしてくれないね
そこでも道徳は、なんかすごい
トラブルになっちゃうんです
人はとりあえず、いくらかの決まり、
基準を設けて
曖昧中途半端で生きているが、
「正義」に適った生き方をしている
のではありません。
そういう訳で、我々はなんとかなんとか
曖昧中途半端で
…まあ、生きてるんですよ
「それが正義」ということには
ならないんですね
食べたいんだから
魚を食うか食わないか、という
魚の肉は、まあおいしくて
身体にいいんですね
だから、健康で長生きしたければ
魚を食べることでしょう？
そうすると魚はどうなるんですかね？
魚の生きる権利は全部
ハチャメチャ奪われて
死んじゃいますね
例えば人間ではなくて
ライオンに道徳を教える
生命は生きる権利があるんだからね
命を取るなよ、と
ライオンは決めなくちゃ…
道徳を破って生きるか
道徳を守って死ぬか、という…
どちらでも非道徳なんですね
だけど存在欲で生きてるんだから
生き続ける行為が善行為なんです
しかし他人にも生きる権利があるんだから
それを奪うことも悪行為なんです
ライオンが
どうすればいいんですかね（笑）
じゃあ獲物を獲らないことにしちゃうと
ライオンが自分の生存欲に
適した行為をやってないんです
悪行為をやっていて
悪結果になるんです
痩せて痩せて飢えて
死ぬという…
それが悪結果なんです
だから行為が悪いんです
じゃあわかった、もう獲物を獲る、と
走り回って獲物を獲って食べちゃうと
その獲物の生きる権利を奪っちゃったんです
それも悪行為です
じゃあ、どうしますかねぇ
はい、次に行きます
今まで説明したのは
世の中の立場で見ると
道徳っていうことは、
すごく…なんか…訳もわからない
どうすればいいか分からない世界なんです
キリスト教の道徳を守るか
イスラム教の道徳を守るか
ヒンドゥー教の道徳を守るのか
仏教の道徳を守るのか
分からなくなっちゃうんです
国が定めた道徳を守るのか、とか
だから世の中にしっかりした
道徳理論がないんです
そこで、こころが基準っていうのは
仏教の立場ですからね
仏教の正義の設定に入りましょう
自己の判断と自由
両方仏教は守ってるんです
仏教的に言えば
人は自分の判断で生きるべきです
行為をこころが決めるので
こころをチェックする必要があります
だから一人ひとりが
自分の心をチェックしなさい、と
汚れたこころで行為をすると
苦しみに陥る。不幸になる
心中心に考えてるんですね
汚れた心で行為をすると
あなた、もう不幸になりますよ、と
清らかなこころで行為をすると幸福になる
個人は幸福になりたいんです
だったら、あなたの心が清らかか
汚れているかと
チェックしてください、と
この教えに合わせて
こころの状況をチェックするんです
で、チェックする方法っていうのは
すごく簡単なんですけど
例えば自分が嘘をつく、と
へっちゃらで、なんのことなく
嘘をつく
嘘をついちゃうと、あなた
幸福になるのか、と
ならないねぇ
自分の伴侶、相手に嘘をつく
これで家族生活が壊れて
信頼できなくなる
会社の同僚に嘘をつくと
会社で仕事ができなくなる
裁判で嘘をついちゃうと
逮捕されてしまいます（笑）
罰金を払わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃう
不幸になったでしょうに
そういう訳で
嘘は悪行為であって
嘘をつかないことが善行為であると
決めることができます
はい
次に「存在の罠」っていう…
これも
仏教の概念なんですね
存在がありがたい、と
思うのは他宗教なんです
「かけがえのない命」とかね
「尊い命」「授かった命」
「神様から預かった命」とか
もう…
評価するわするわ…
なんの根拠もなく
いいかげんにね
仏教的にはこれって罠だよ、と
存在…
ひと言葉抜けてます…存在…
…は、渇愛で成り立ってます
存在欲で成り立っています
渇愛は仏教の専門用語なんですね
渇愛がなければ生きられないんです
だからみんな生きていきたい
生きていきたいと思ってるんです
で、渇愛も三つに分けてますけど
今日は説明しないことにします
問題は…この…
疲れたら座る、喉が渇いたら水を飲む
あれこれ、とかね
寂しくなったら、なんか
ネットでも見るとかね
そこで、存在は渇愛でやってます
「生きていきたい！」という
気持ちでやってるんです
誰も聞かないね
何で、そんなに
必死で生きているの？
何でそんなに必死になって
生きていたがる？
ただ高校生が徹夜して
受験勉強をするならば
分かりますね
一流の大学に入りたい、と
そのセクションで考えれば
徹夜して勉強することは善行為なんです
目的がありますから
目的に達しますから
本当に真剣に勉強したら
一流の大学には合格します
それより真剣に生きているでしょうに
目指すゴールはなんですかね
…これが、仏教しか教えていないんですね
罠だと
だって生き続けると歳を取るだけでしょう？
老人を目指して生きている？
どんどん身体が衰えて病気にかかるでしょう？
「私は、色んな病気にかかりたくて
がんばってますよ」と
成り立たないね
誰だって最終的には死ぬでしょう？
「私は死を目指して
しっかり生きてますよ」
成り立たたない話ですね
ということは
あなたは一生懸命生きていても
得るものはまったくないんです
ゼロです。皆無です
なのにがんばってるところは
罠でしょう？
あなたに絶対給料をあげませんけど
一日十時間仕事をしなさい、と
やる？それだったら
徹夜で仕事をさせられちゃって
水一杯もくれないで
朝になったら「朝だから仕事を
続けてやってください」と
言うと、やる？
何かご褒美がないと
仕事をすると給料をもらうという
日本のシンプルなケースでしょう？
子供がお母さんに
ちょっと何か協力してあげたら
お母さんが「ありがとう」と
言ってくれると
そこで気分がよくなります
そこで結果があるんですね
「お母さんに褒めてもらった」と
子供がなんかすごくいい気分になる
そういう小さな小さなところで
人がご褒美を目指してがんばってるのに
全体的に生きることってなんですかね
あれはすべて sap（樹液）でしょうに
生きていることがベースで、その上で
仕事したり、ご飯を作ったり食べたり
友達と仲良くしたりするんですね
sap でやってるものには
それなりのご褒美があるんです
本業では得られるものは何もないんです
本業という生きることがなければ
副業も成り立たないんです
だからみんなこの副業に
すごく執着していますね
金に執着するわ、家族に執着するわ
会社に執着するわ
自分の知識に執着するわ
おしゃれに執着するわ
すべて副業です
本業じゃないんです
そんなの一時的なもので
全部捨てなくてはいけません
それで、生きることがあって
全部やっています
生きることをよくよく見ると
すごい罠で、何も得られない
その上で
生きることに障害が起こると
怒り、嫉妬、憎しみ、落ち込みなどの
煩悩が起こるんです
スムーズに生きられないんですね
ものすごいトラブルが起こるんです
そこでさらに心を汚しちゃいます
ということで、存在欲自体が
成り立たなくなりますね
存在欲で生きることが道徳だと言っても
よく見るとこれは罠で
存在欲すら成り立たない
生きられないんです
邪魔ばっかりで
迷惑ばっかりで
焼けてしまう
ギリギリでパッと死ぬならばいいんだけど
それでもないんですね
すごく苦労して苦労して苦労して
やっと死ぬということには
なってますね
そこでフレーズは「生きていきたいが、
生きられない」ということなんです
両足に
短い鎖をつけて
速く走るというんです
走れないでしょうに
「速く速く！」と…
鎖をつけてるんだから
これ幅が短いんだから
走ろうとしたらこけちゃうんです
「ゆっくり歩いちゃうといいんだけど…」
「いいえ！走りなさい」と
それが人生です
はい
まだ存在の罠が続きます
「生きる戦い」が上手く進まないと、
人は状況を調べて、間違いを学んで観る
まあ、みんなやってますよ、それは
なんで上手く行ってないのか、と
そこから、より良い生き方、
正しい生き方、
道徳、成功の秘訣などが現れるのです。
みんなだいたいそんなことをやってますよ
どうすれば会社の同僚と
仲良くできるのか、とかね
上司がいつでも、すごく怒るんだけど
怒らないようにどうすればよいか
怒られないようにどうすればいいか、とかね
それをやってみたら
またうまく行かなくなると
また道徳を改良するんですね
それで、普通の人々は
「負けたー」とは言わないで
いろんな工夫して工夫して
がんばってはいるんです
そうすると個人の世界でも
ずーっと道徳が変わって変わって
変わっていくんです
これで悪循環になるんですね
生きていきたいが、生かしてくれない
ことでも矛盾があるでしょうに
生きたからと言って得るものは
何もないんだから
なんでそんなに必死で生きるのかい、と
そちらの問題があるんだから
だから副業に執着する訳に
なってます
それもうまく行かないし
ということは人間が
この存在欲だけに集中してるんだけど
人間、一つ考えてないんですね
「なんで生き続けたいのか」と
調べてない
どうすれば上司に怒られないのかと
私にも聞きますけど
あの質問は誰も聞いたことはないんです
なんで人はそんなに必死で
生きたがるのか、と
面白いでしょう？
長い間日本で喋ってきたんだけど
質問を受けてきたんだけど
あの質問は来ないんです
…この質問
なぜ、そんなに生き続けたいんですか、と
それは仏教用語で「無明」という言葉に
していますね
あなた、足元が見えてないよ、と
存在欲って、とんでもない罠だ、と
はい、次に行きます
次のタイトルは「正義は成り立たない」（笑）
成り立たないね、結局は
存在欲があるならば、それに伴う
貪・瞋・痴などの感情があるならば、
こころは常に、汚れていることになります。
存在欲があるでしょう？
それで生かしてくれないでしょう？
そうすると怒ったりもします
あるいはうまく行ったらすごく
欲を抱いたりもする
だから、いつだって心が汚れているんです
いつだって心が汚れているんだったら
いつだってあなたがやっていることは
道徳ではないんです
存在欲のある生命が行うこと
すべて悪行為で
道徳になってないんですね
だから正義は成り立たないんです
Righteousness（正義）ということは
成り立たないんです
汚れたこころで行う判断も起こす行為も
不正で、悪行為になります。
こころを観察しない人に、
正義に適った生き方は出来ません
心を観てください、と。でない限りは
正義に適った生き方はできません
人の躾に合わせて他人の指令に従うより
他の方法はありません。
だから、みんな手を上げて
人が言う通りに、他人の躾に従って
まあロボットになって生きているんです
ロボットになったことが正義
ということでもないんです
しかし、いつでも不完全で、それなら
不自由な生き方になります。
だから、人の生き方はすべて
不自由になってるんです
だって、人から教えてもらって
やってるでしょう？…不自由です
はい、そういうことで、俗世間では
正義は成り立たないという結論になるんです
はい、次に行きます
はい、これから正義の道を
探しましょう
正義はないんです、世の中で
道徳は成り立ってないんです
こころの汚れをチェックする生き方なので、
仏陀が説かれる道は普遍的なものです。
お釈迦様が「心をチェックしなさい」
それで全部終わりです、道徳は
すごく単純なワンフレーズで
オープニングで私は
Sabba pāpassa akaraṇaṃ, kusalassa upasampadā
と言ったでしょう？
三行目にSacitta pariyodapanaṃ
それが正義なんです
Sacitta...いわば、自分の心を
清らかにしなさい
それだけだ、と
etaṃ Buddhāna sāsanaṃ
それがブッダの教えである、と
それが正義なんです
世の中には、残念ながらないんです
他宗教に残念ながらないんです
哲学では、残念ながらないんです
学校の道徳の授業では
絶対、道徳のひとかけらもないんです
この「心を清らかにしなさい」ということは
好き勝手に変わる道徳じゃないんです
我々が俗世間で守る道徳は
すぐすぐ変わっちゃいますよ
だから十年前我々が正しいとやった
生き方を、今はやらないんですね
世界が変わると
道徳価値観も変わってしまいます
そんないいかげんで
…な道徳ではないんです
お釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
普遍的な道徳
この普遍的っていうのは
ユニバーサルっていうのは
すごく深い意味があるんです
仏教では、この宇宙がこのまま
いる訳じゃないんだよ、と
これは破壊しますよ、と
この太陽様が偉大なる力を
発揮しているんだけど
やがて破壊しますよ、と
だから宇宙が破壊して無になったところで
また、ふたたび宇宙が現れるんです
で、そこは仏教はへっちゃらで
言っちゃいますね
ビッグバン、ビッグクランチの方式は
vivaṭṭa-kappa（成劫）
vivaṭṭa-ṭhāyin-kappa（住劫）
saṃvaṭṭa-kappa（壊劫）
saṃvaṭṭa-ṭhāyin-kappa（空劫）
という四つに分けて語ってるんです
vivaṭṭa-kappaというのは
ビッグバンから世界が広げる
広げて…止まる
止まっても、ものすごい時間がたつ
それから収縮を始める
始めて、あるところで止まる
止まったら破壊する
これはもう、人に想像できないくらい
すごい時間がかかる作業です
どうやって宇宙が四ステージで
現れては消えるんだから
そこで生命も同じです
生命も何かしらで生き続けるんです
宇宙が破壊したからといって
問題ないんです
それで、その環境に合わせて
生命の形も変わります
人間の形は、太陽が爆発しちゃうと
なくなりますけどね
でも、生命として別なシステムに
変わるんです
そこで、宇宙がどんな風に変化して
いっても
生命はそれに合わせて合わせて
現れるんだから
どんなときでも生命は
自分の心で行為を判断するんです
ですから「心をチェックしなさい」
という道徳が
普遍的な道徳なんです
十年、百年で変わる道徳では
ありません
宇宙法則です
宇宙が現れて消えて行っても
生命もそこで現れるんだから
生命はいつだって心で判断するんです
はい、ではお釈迦様のメッセージに
入りましょう
順番にすごい真理に、正義に達すること
順番に進んでみましょう
ⅰこれから行う行為は自分のためになる。
行為をする場合は、まず自分のために
やってるんです
誰だって自分のためにやっているんです
しかし、他人に迷惑、害を与える
行為であるならば
不幸な結果になりますよ
自分のために良いんだけど
他人にはすごく害を与える行為
不幸で結果になる行為は
やめた方がいい
ⅱ番目
行為は他人のためになる。
ただ自分が持ってるお金を
人にあげちゃう
他人のためになる
しかし、自分の行為が
人の役に立つんだけど
その結果、自分が不幸になるならば
問題です
他人を幸せにしようということで
自分が不幸になる
自分の存在が危うい状態になると
問題です
自分を不幸に陥れる行為は
善行為ではないんです
気をつけて下さい
人に幸福をあげることは悪いことではないよ
しかし、自分を不幸に陥れるならば
これは悪行為です
だから…
うーん…大変ですよ
ⅲ番目
自分の幸福になる行為ですが
他人に不幸を与えない。
これは△（三角形）
自分で静かに仕事をして
自分でスーパーで買い物をして
ご飯を作って食べて、お風呂に入って
それから寝て、また起きて
生きてても誰にも迷惑じゃないでしょうね
人と会ったら挨拶をして
隣の家にも迷惑をかけないで
密かに生きる…自分のためにそれはいい
他人に迷惑もかけてない
それは善行為でしょうか、というと△で
まあ、善行為になるでしょう、と
と言うんです
ⅳ番目
行為は自分のためにもなるし、
他人のためにもなります。
自分がやってることで自分も幸せになるし
周りも幸せになります
これは◎（二重丸）で善行為なんです
そうやって自分で善行為を
判断しなくてはいけません
善行為にはどうしても
生命が関係あるんです
はい。順番の次
結果を推定する
それで、私がいちばん最初に出した
スライドと違うことを、今言っています
結果が起こる前に
ちょっと予測してみましょう、と
これは時間のチェックなんですね
ⅰ行う前に、行為は自分と他人の幸福を
もたらすものかとチェックする。
ちょっと予測してみる
「こういうことをやりたいんだけど
これをやっちゃうと私も他の人々も
幸福になるのでしょうか」と
やる前にチェックするんです
まだやってないんだから分からないよ？
一応推測する
「ああ、これはいいこと」
と分かったら、やるしかないんですね
ⅱ番目。まあ、やるんです、行為を
やるときは、今現在進行形だから
結果もそれなりに見えてくるんでしょう？
まだこれ完成してないんです
具体的に、じゃあ嘘をつくという
ことにしましょう
自分が嘘をついて人を騙す目的で
嘘のストーリーを作って話している
そこで、話し始めたところからその人は
相手が自分の話に乗っているか乗って
いないか、チェックするでしょう
嘘をつくときっていつでも
そういうことでしょう？
相手を気を引いて引いてもらって
乗らせるんですね
乗って話が終了すると
相手がまんまと騙されているんです
ですからこちらで言うのは善行為
善行為…この善行為をやった方が
私と他人の幸せなるんだよと思って
実行する
実行するときでも
淡々とチェックしてほしい
チェックしてみると
「あら？幸せになる予定でしたけど…
何か迷惑もかけてるようだ」とかね
分かってくると中断できますよ
悪い結果を出さないで、ほんのちょっとの
悪い結果で中断できるんです
ⅱ行っている時も、行為が道徳基準に
合っているか否かをチェックする。
ⅲ番目。行ってから自分と他人の
幸福になったか否かをチェックする。
行為は終わっちゃった
終わってからもう結果があるんです
この結果はあまりよくない
この結果はいい、と分かったら
次のステップが判断できる
リピートするか、二度とやらないか、と
そういうステップで、一般の人々は
自分の生き方を
チェックしなくちゃいけない
それが道徳的な生き方で
これた難しいとは思わないよ？
なぜならば
これは、お釈迦様が自分の息子であった
ラーフラ尊者に教えたものなんです
ラーフラ尊者は子供でしょう？
子供にも実行できるんです
悪だと発見した時点で中止するので、
危険は最小限になるんですね
そういう順番で我々は生きてみるんです
はい、次に進みます
次に感情をチェックするんです
ラーフラ尊者に行為をチェックしなさい
と言ったのは
まあ、心の中を観るまでは
もしかすると
大人になってなかったかもね
だから人とケンカする前に考えて
ケンカしていいのか、と
あんたは幸せになるのかい、と
相手は幸せになるのかい、と
ならないんだったらやめてくださいよ、と
いう程度で
そこで、もうちょっと大人になってくると
感情をチェックできますね
心の衝動をチェック
感情をチェックよりも
欲が活動中なら判断しない、行為をしない。
自分の感情をチェックすると
今、欲が活動中
欲が働いている
何もしない。判断もしない
欲が収まるまでいるんです
しゃべったりしてはあかんです
何をしゃべるか分からないんだから
そこで行為を調整するんです
怒りが活動中なら判断しない、行為をしない。
無知が活動中なら判断しない、行為をしない。
それほど難しくない
心の感情が悪いんだったら「止まれ」
それだけ。何もしないで
心が落ち着いてきたら
行動してください
怒ったら止まりなさいよ
いきなり欲が出てきたら
行動してはいけない。止まるんです
よく電車に看板が見えますけど
「痴漢は犯罪です」とかね
あれって痴漢ってどういうことかと見ると
特に女性の方々を触ったりして
悪いことをするんですね
だから男性が女性にすごい欲がある
欲の感情が上がってくる
すぐ行為をする。犯罪でしょうに
だから電車に乗っていて
誰かを見たところで欲が生まれてきたら
じーっと何もしないで
こらえていなくてはいけません
そうすると、悪行為・犯罪を
犯したことにならないんです
黙ってるんです
電車で誰かハイヒールの人が
自分の足を踏みつけたら
超痛いでしょうね
もう、腹が立ちますね
「このバカな女、気をつけろよ」と
言いたくなるでしょう
「ハイヒールを履いてるって…ハイヒールを
履いたら、それに気をつけて歩きなさいよ」と
「お前アホか」と
言いたいんですけど…
言わないでこらえた方がいいんです
おんなじ対応
そこで何も分からなくて
「もうどうでもいいや」状態でも
何も判断しないで、心が明晰に
なるまで待った方がいいんです
それで道徳的な人間になります
で、こころが不貪・不瞋・不痴で
あるならば
行為は幸福をもたらす善になります
心には、不貪・不瞋・不痴だったら
だいたいセットは一緒になりますからね
清らかな心だったら
ああ、やってくださいよ
しゃべったり、笑ったり、話したり
色んなことをやってくださいよ、と
それはすべて善行為になりますよ、と
そういうチェックをするんですね
感情チェック
次のステージは「学ぶ」ということなんです
正義の世界ってそう単純じゃないんです（笑）
四番目のステージは「学ぶ」
学ぶことは人の定めなので
仏法を学んでみてください
人間に生まれたら
学ぶことは、もう運命になってるんです
世の中で学ぶものは無数に、無限にあります
だったら、唯一、智慧のある人の
教えを学んだらどうですかね
頭がイカれてるモーゼの言葉を
学ぶんじゃなくて
学んでもいいんだけど
道徳の勉強にはならないんです
エジプトのファラオたちの
死後の考えに触れて
学んでもいいんだけど
道徳的に自分には何の役にも立たない
ですから、一生かかる事ばっかり
世の中にあるのは、ね
だから真理を発見したブッダの教えを
学んでみたらどうですかね
そこでサッと頭がよくなりますよ
仏教を学んだだけでもよい人間になるんです
それでお釈迦様の教えっていうのは
完全な教えで
理論と実践、理論と実践で授業なんです
理論を教えてやってみてください
結果をチェックしてくださいという
教えですから
ただの授業ではないんですね
だからお釈迦様は簡単に
「まあ、嘘をつくなよ」と
「生命を殺すなよ」と
…やってみるんです
シンプルで
虎の例えなんか持ってこないで（笑）
まあ「殺生しない」と
やってみる、そうするとなんとなく
自分が、すごく気持ちよくなりますよ
ああ、いい人間で生きてるんだ、と
人格が向上しているんだと
経験できますよ
それから、智慧
世の中色んな知識があるんだけど
結局は、究極の、真理の真理は
「苦・無常・無我」なんです
科学者は宇宙の生滅を見ていないでしょう？
ブッダはそこまで見ているんだから
宇宙全体的な現れて消えることだ、と
発見していたんだから
だから何万光年でも遡ってみても
やっぱり、いつだって物は止まらない
変化する
物すら存在しない
だから法則を決めたんです
「無常・苦・無我」
無常というとすべての物事が入る
苦といったら、無我といったら
生命の真理なんです
それをちょっと学んでみたら
どうでしょうか、と
それから、因縁の教えを
学んでみるんです
因縁の教えで「物は成り立たない」
ということを教えるんです
例えばロウソクに日を点けちゃうと
炎があるんですね
炎が実在しますか、と
本当にそこで実体として炎があるか
というとそうじゃないんです
炎がずーっと消えて消えて消えて
新しい炎になるんです
見えるんですね、蝋が溶けて上がって
ガスになって燃えて
次の蝋が上がってガスになって…
止まることなく流れるんですね
そこで炎のような錯覚があるんだけど
炎も止まることなく変化しているんです
それって因果法則なんです
因果法則を知ったら
すべてロウソクの炎のようであると
わかるんです
なにかに当たって自分が痛くなっても
じっと観るんですね
当たった、ドギャーンと痛くなった
それから
当たってないんだから
じわじわと痛みが消えていく
だから痛みっていうのは
止まってる現象ではないんです
あるいは、どうやってお腹が空くんですか？
一発で、突然、all of a sudden（突然）
…ではないんです
じわじわじわじわと
で、最終的には気づくほど
「あ、お腹が空いた」と感じるんでしょうに
すべてはそういうことなんです
止まってないんです
だから自分というのは錯覚
ただロウソクの炎があるー！
と思ってるような感じなんです
そうやって因果法則を学んでみるんです
学んだことは実践して試してみるんです
例えば、ハイヒールに踏まれて
すごく痛くなると
「私がいる」「この人がいる」
「踏まれた」「痛みがある」と
個体で「ある」と思っちゃうと
ものすごく腹が立つんです
物が変化するんだ、と
あの人が意図的に来て踏んだことでもないし
状況によって体が揺れちゃって
自分の体を安定しなくてはいけないから
足を持っていったところで
人の足の上に行っちゃっただけで
自分が痛みを感じたのは刺されたところで
痛いんだけど
じーっと時間が経つと痛みが
ちょこちょこちょこ…っと消えてくる
そうやって、すべて流れるものだ、と
止まっているものはないと分かると
けっこうカッコいいんですよ？
はい、次に行きます
ステップ⑤
こころの進化
心を進化させないといけません
思考・妄想を止めて
こころの流れをチェックする。
今まで世の中をチェックしたんですからね
自分の心が流れるわ流れるわ…
それをチェックするんです
なぜ、貪・瞋・痴が起こるのかをチェックする。
存在欲＜渇愛＞が原因であることを発見する。
こんなに必死で馬鹿になっちゃって
罠に引っかかって生きてるのは
存在欲…ああ存在欲があるんだ
生きていきたい、と
なんで生きていきたいという気持ちが
あるんでしょうかねぇ、とかね
心をチェックするんです
如実に現象の姿を発見してないから、
我々は、ありのままに「物は存在しない」
ということを発見していないんです
一切無常ということを発見してないんです
だから「私」がいる
私がいるんだったら「死にたくない」と
そういう幻覚ばっかり生まれるんですね
「私、他、もの」があると思っちゃうんです
実在すると思うから問題が起きて、
こころが汚れると発見する。
ああ、だから心が汚れるんだ、と
存在欲がある
だって馬鹿で見てなかったんだから
心の流れを見るとよく分かるんですね
私がいなかったら他人もいないし
ものもないでしょうに、と
私という現象の仕組み、
存在の仕組みを調べる。
それでどうやって私という幻覚が現れるのか、と
それは眼耳鼻舌身意をチェックすると
いたって簡単ですね
眼耳鼻舌身意とは
六種類のロウソクの炎ですよ
六本のロウソクの炎があるだけで
これ、一つのロウソクの炎が
固まってる訳じゃない
固まったと勘違いする
だって六本のロウソクを立てたら
明かりがけっこうありますからね
それで錯覚を起こすんです
はい、次に行きます
これで最後かもしれません
こころの超越⑥
問題は心が作ったんだからね
それをやっつけるんです
集中力を高めて、
現象が起こる『瞬間』を発見するんです
これは仏教科学ではかなり大変な
解脱の瞬間なんですね
この瞬間というのは time なんですね
科学の世界では「ナノ秒」というものを
考えてますけど
ナノ秒というのは、人間に想像できる
時間じゃないんです
すっごく短いんですね
一秒の百万分の一か何かですね
仏教の瞬間というのは
どちらかよく分からないんだけど
ナノ秒と同じか、同じでないのかは
分かりませんけど
瞬間を認識できれば
すべて現れて消えるものだと
いうことは分かるんです
例えば音っていうのは
0.5秒ぐらい聞いたら
音になるんですよ
音は、スピーカーの音でも
我々は
一秒の百分の一だけの時間、聞く
…音になってないんです
最低、0.5秒ぐらい音を聞かないと
ですからこの瞬間を経験するという
ことは仏教の修行では
まあ目指しているところで
瞬間を観た人には
すべて存在しないということが
観えてくるんです
自も他も幻想であって、実在しない
のだと発見する。
そこで、無知・無明が消えるので
…無知と無明が消えたんです
それに言葉で「智慧」と言うんです
そこで面白いことに
存在欲が成り立つんです
存在欲があるならば
道徳が必要なんです
存在欲がなかったならば
道徳から解放されているんです（笑）
存在欲が智慧でなくなるんです
で、二度と存在欲が現れないんですね
なくなったら
それで正義の道は終了です
それで六ステップに分けて
正義を教えたんです
善も悪も成り立たない境地です
まあ言葉で仏教では涅槃というんだけど
それは理解できないんですね、まあ
…現象の世界では
それで、正義も終わり
正義の道を歩んで、やっと
「はい、終わった」ということになるんです
はい、次に行きます
他人を正す、という
だいたい俗世間で正義の味方という
単語があるんですね
あれって超気持ち悪い単語で
他人（ひと）を正す、というね…
冗談じゃないんです
存在欲がある人にできる仕事ではありません。
存在欲がある人は
何が道徳か、何が非道徳か
自分でも分かってないんです
どうやって人に教えるんですかね
人は「自己を正す」
正義の味方になるのです。
ですから、我々は自己を探す
自分を直す
正義の味方にならなくちゃいけない
他を直すのではないんです
みんな正義の味方になってほしいんですが…
…自分を直すために…
あの六つのステップで
自分を直さなくちゃいけないんですね
正義の味方とは自分自身の修行であって、
他人の過ちを言いふらす生き方では
ありません。
正義の味方っていうのは
自分を直すんです
他人の過ちを、あの人は悪い
この人は悪い、あれやこれやとか
そんな世界じゃないんです
あれは自我の行為ですからね
他人を正す、戒めることは、
正等覚者・仏陀の仕事です。
それはブッダにまかせてください
仏陀は人権を侵害しないで
指導するのです。
これは人にできることじゃないんです
人が「嘘をつくな」と言ったら
腹が立ちますよ
自分の人権を侵害したんです
しかし、お釈迦様が「嘘をつくなよ」
と言ったら
「ああ、ありがとうございます」
という気持ちになるんです
ちょっと読んでみてください
人権侵害をしないで
ものの見事に道徳を教えているんです
だから、それはブッダにしかできる仕事
…でしょう
はい、次
そこで我々の問題があります
互いに協力する仲間
仏教徒は互いに協力し合って生活します
仏教徒たちは互いに
いつでも助け合わなくちゃいけない
誰も完璧という訳ではないんだけど
助け合わなければいけないんですね
学んだ人は、先輩は後輩を指導します。
教えます。
だからといって
その人が超偉い訳じゃないんです
仏教を学んだ人は人に教えたからといって
すべて知り尽くしている訳でもないんです
それを理解してほしいんです
人は自分の能力範囲で相手を助けてあげる
しかし、だれにも他人を支配する
権利はありません。
特に仏教の世界では
支配権は誰にもないんです
お互い仲間で協力し合ってください
ボスはいませんよ、と
みんな完璧じゃないんだから
あなたに教えても
その人にも間違いはありますよ、と
和合して、調和を保って、
仲間に慈悲喜捨を実践して、
皆、正義の道を歩んで
善悪を越えた境地を目指します。
仏道の仲間、仏教徒たちはそういう風に
ものすごく気をつけて和合を保つんです
調和を保つんです
いつでも仲良くすることだけを
考えるんです
人の過ちを許してあげるんです
人に何か教えたくなったら
すごく慈悲の心で
相手の人権を侵害しないで
教えてあげたりするという
けっこう大変な修行の世界なんです
とても素晴らしい仏教の世界は
お釈迦様の仏教徒の世界は
お釈迦様が考えてはいるんです
すごく…なんか兄弟のように、家族のように
互いに協力し合う
支配者はいません
という世界を考えているんです
はい
それで終わりと…
今日の正義の味方の話はそれで終わりです
すごく難しくなったような気がしますけど
やっぱり俗世間では道徳が
成り立ってないということは
言いたくて
道徳はそんな単純に言えるものではないんです
それは心の問題なんです
心に汚れがあると道徳ではない
ですから心を清らかにしなさい、と
Sacittapariyodapanaṃ（自らのこころを清めること）
それも自分でやらなくてはいけないんです
だからこれは善に「なる」方法なんです
正義に達したら、正義も終わりです
正義を背負って行かないんです（笑）
はい、以上です。ありがとうございます
（拍手）
（司会）スマナサーラ先生
ありがとうございました
一応、今日は四時半終了の
予定ですのであと二十分ちょっと
時間がございます
久しぶりに、リアルでご質問の
コーナーをとりたいと思いますけど
質問ある方いらっしゃいますか？
挙手していただけますか
いかがでしょうか
疑問がない、皆さん（笑）
完全に理解した、ということで
よろしいでしょうか
遠慮なさらずに…
どなたか手を挙げていらっしゃいます
ああ、はい
（質問者1）ありがとうございました
どなたも質問がないということで
ちょっと質問…後ほど先生に質問してしまうと
時間…と先生に申し訳ないので
こちらでさせてください
私は…布マスクってご存知ですよね
国が廃棄するという記事を見てですね
これはもう…もったいないと
いうんじゃないですけど、もう一度
活かして、そして廃棄してもらいたい
ということで
先生方にですね…
スマナサーラ先生の
スリランカのお寺とか村の人達とか
そういうところでもう一度活動
できるかな、という
提案をさせていただいたんですけど
今日のお話を聞いてると、私の…
結局、もったいないという欲みたいなことと
なんかその辺りでこれは一歩
留まらなければいけないのかな、と
と思うような気がしましたので、先生に
ちょっとそこは私の行為は善行為じゃなくて
自分のわがままという感じの
いつもの癖みたいなものが
今発生してるのかなと思うと
一歩、止まりなさい、考えなさいという
ことを、先生に今教えていただきましたら
ああ、私ちょっと間違ってるかなと
思いましたので
そのあたりを教えてください
よろしくお願い致します
ワガママなことをやってきたな、と
分かったら、それからやらないだけでしょう？
（質問者1）そうは思わないんですけど
一歩踏みとどまって、みんなが幸せに
なるんだったら、やりなさいということを
自分はみんなが幸せになると
思ったんですけれども
まだ心の中に自分の…もったいない
というか、そして…あのう…
スリランカの方たちに
「これを活用できませんか」みたいな
そういうのって、なんか
失礼だったのかな、とか
思ったりしたんですけれども
本人は…私としたらこれは良いことだと
思ってやってるんですけど
お釈迦様の教え（不明）
ちょっと踏みとどまってみなきゃいけない
自分があったのかなと、今日の説法を
聞きまして思いましたので
ちょっと教えてください、という
質問です。よろしくお願いします
あまりにもあれこれと考え…
妄想しているから何を聞いてるか
よく分からないしね
（司会）えーとですね、先生はあまりニュースを
見ないのでご存知ないかもしれませんけど
アベノマスクって言って
去年ですかね…
一家に二枚ずつ
布マスクを配ったということで
けっこう話題になったじゃないですか
あのマスクが大量に余っていて
それで保管費用が
何十億円もかかるということで
今の岸田さんという総理大臣が
「もうこれは廃棄します」と
まあ、廃棄した方がお金がかからないので
持っていても布マスクなんて今どき誰も使わないので
「もう捨てます」と言ったそうですね
それで、この方が、それはちょっともったいないので
なんかスリランカとかに持っていったら
なんか有効活用してもらえるんじゃないか
ということを考えたそうです
そのことが、今ご説法を聞いて
ちょっとそれはまずかったんじゃないかな
という風に
というか、ちょっと…ちょっと
なんか迷いが…というか
どう考えればいいのか、と
いうことですね？
（長老）（笑）
関係ないことですね
（質問者1）すいません。ごめんなさい
先生、私のファックスをお読みになってない
ということが、今分かりましたので
私の…なんというんですか
提案というか、先生に対して
このファックスを
選んでいただいて
締め切りが一月十四日までですから
それぞれが個人とか団体が一月十四日
までに申し込めるとか、無料でそして
申し込んだ人のところへ無料で送って
くださるんですけども
ゴータミーで申し込んだとすれば
無料でゴータミーに何万と来るんですけど
だけど、もし私がスリランカに
送りたいとなったとき
ゴータミーからスリランカに
持っていく輸送代とかいうものは
どうなるかというのがあるので
私の一つの考えとしては
一時帰国するスリランカの人たちに
先生のお寺に届けるように
するとか、それから後はもう一つは
スリランカ大使館にお願いして
先生のお寺に、無料で届けて
くださいますかって私は
お願いをしようと思ってたんですけど
まずはスマナサーラ先生に
お尋ねしてから行動しなければ
いけないな、と
で、もしゴータミーのところで
何万かほしいということは
まあ、ヤサ長老様がいらっしゃるので
その長老様とか
こちらの佐藤さんなんかが
佐藤（不明）ですね…が
手続きを
えーと、あれはなんて言うんですかね
厚労省にインターネットで申し込めば今
やっておりますので、そこのところを
ファックスでお尋ねしたんですけど、まだ
スマナサーラ先生のお耳には入って
ないということが、今分かりましたので
えーと、これはもう一回ゼロから
スタートさせていただきます
（スマナサーラ長老）そんな執着で
やっても迷惑だけでしょうに
その考えを捨てればどうですかね
この…アベ…なんとかさんが送ったマスクは
布のマスクでしょう？
あれは医療的には禁止なんです
私が診療所に行く場合は一回、布マスク
呼吸しやすいものをつけていたんですね
「それを直ちに外してください」と
診療所から別なマスクをくれたんです
ですから
体を守ってくれない布マスクを…
なんで処分しないんですかね？
（司会）あの…色々と政治的な…
一国の首相が決めて作ったものを
そんな簡単に捨てられないということで
ずっと取っておいて何億円もお金を
使ってたんですけど
安倍さんが辞めて、菅さんが総理になって
菅さんも辞めたので
一代おいたので、もういいだろう
という感じで
捨てることにしたんだろうと
私は思いますけど。はい
（質問者1）はい
（司会者）ちょっとすみません…
（質問者1）先生、もう一言
私がファクスで提案したのは
布マスクがこういう風に広がるんですよね
だから、これをマスクじゃなくて
他の…後でいいですか？
はい、分かりました
（司会）すみません、他の方で
なにか質問があれば…
あ、ちょっと遠いので…
ちょっと待ってください
最初に上げた奥の方ですね
まず奥の方にお聞きしてから
手前の方にマイクを渡します
（質問者2）先生（不明）と申します
正義という先ほどの英語の訳ですね
Righteousという言葉ですけれど
これが英語で正義…Justice…その言葉
RighteousとJusticeの
違いはなんでしょうか
同じニュアンスでしょうか
違うね。Justiceっていうのは
ちょっとレベルが低い単語なんですね
それは、人間の間で行うことであってね
Righteousnessというのはそうではなくて
個人個人でも守らなくては
いけないんですね
Justiceは成り立たないと思いますよ
どうしてもね
凶暴者が
握っちゃいますからね、存在の中で
弱者には生きづらいっていうのはあるし
だから、Justiceでも
凶暴者が打ち勝つんですね
だから、あんまり意味がないんです
人間社会だけに限った、ちょっとした
問題なんですね
とにかく、ランク的にはRighteousnessって
いうのはいちばん上のランクなんです
Justiceは、あるリミットの中で
使える単語なんですね
Justiceの場合は、自分がどう判断するのか
という判断だけであって
Righteousnessっていうのは、どう正しく
生きるのかということで
研究して研究して
正しく生きることになるんです。はい
（司会）それでは、もう一方
これで最後の質問にしたいと思います
（質問者3）ありがとうございました
今日のお話の中の感情のチェックで
欲が活動中なら判断しない
怒りが活動中なら判断しない
無知が活動中なら判断しない、という
お話があったと思うんですが
欲と怒りは分かりやすいですけど
無知が活動中っていうのが
なんかちょっとよくわからなくて
だいたい自分が無知な状態に
常にいる気がするんですが
そこについて、もう少し詳しく
お話をお伺いしたいです
（スマナサーラ長老）まあ、無知が
活動する時というのは
自分でも、もうどうすればいいか
分からない状態
何を言えばいいか、と
どうすればいいか、と
その場合はみんな
なんとかしちゃいますね
その時は「今、頭が混乱してるんだから
何もしない」という風にした方がいいんですね
無知っていうのは、心が
明確に働かないときなんです
すごく曇ってるときなんですね
怒りと欲は、はっきりしていますよね
そういう、はっきりしない
なんか、心がすごく曖昧中途半端に
なっちゃって
「まあ…いいや、どうでもいいや」って
気持ちなんですね
無気力状態
落ち込み状態
まあ無知が活動している時なんです
はい
（司会）はい。それでは
では、もう一方。最後に
質問していただきたいと思います
このままどうぞ
（質問者4）sacittapariyodapanaṃ
（自らの心を清めること）ということを、ちょっと
自分の毎日に置き換えて
考えてみたんですけど
なにか起こった時に、自分がこうしたいな
ということを措いておいて
いま起きている状況の中で
「あ、じゃあこれだったらこうしなきゃ
私はこうしたいけど、それだったらこうしなきゃ」
っていう、そんなことを続けていくと
自我がなくなって…
なくなってというか、薄くなって
まあ、やがてそうすると自我がないところには
ダンマがある、みたいな、そんなイメージで
ちょっと聞いたんですけど
そんな理解でどうでしょうか？
という質問です
よろしくお願いします
（スマナサーラ長老）まあ、質問はないでしょう？
（聴衆：笑）
がんばってください
（司会）はい、それではちょっと
慌ただしくなってしまいましたが
質疑応答のコーナーは
これで終了したいと思います
（スマナサーラ長老）あのね、政府が作った
布パッドをこう使える、ああ使えるとか
そんなに…考え方を捨ててくださいよ
ものすごく執着に感じますけどね
ものごとは捨てるっていうことも
大事なことなんです
無駄遣いしてはいけないっていうことも
大事ですよ。そこらへんで
バランスを取らなくちゃいけないんですね
「どうしてもがんばって、これを
あの国に送りたい、この国に送りたい」と
余計なことをやって向こうに迷惑を
かけていいでしょうか、と
問題も起こるし
安倍さんにしても一人の人間だからね
そんなに賢い人ということには
ならないでしょう
（質問者1）もう一つ言い忘れたんですが
このマスクがこんな風に大きくなるので
マスクだけじゃなくて、他のものに
使ったらどうですかという
提案だったんですね…（以下不明）
（司会）すいません。あとでお願いします
あとでお願いします
（スマナサーラ長老）では
最後のお経で終了します
全部出してください
はい、合掌して…
Dukkhappattā ca niddukkhā
Bhayappattā ca nibbhayā
Sokappattā ca nissokā
Hontu sabbepi pāṇino.
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく、
おそれて悩む生命がおそれなく、
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく、
一切の生命が安穏でありますように。
Sadhu! Sadhu! Sadhu!
はい、ありがとうございます